you've heard the name before surf shark
what do they do vpn's virtual private
network sounds a bit technical sounds a
bit complicated for this slot
it might be that's why they need someone
as smart as you to break it down for
them helps you hide your identity
because a lot of us nowadays we're
worried about people tracking us online
so say you're sitting in a cafe put your
vpn on not only that but it can also put
you in different countries around the
world so you could watch netflix
somewhere but none of that you could
probably sign up for some stuff in
america that you don't normally get
in the uk and where else can i use the
vpn oh that's awkward you can use it
here here
here and on your ipad or on your tablet
once i know
all your devices covered boom unlike a
lot of other vpns out there the best
deal around
now at this point my love you're
probably thinking oh that's going to
cost me a lot i don't know if the
husband's going to let me sign up for
that
eighty-three percent off three months
for free just for using the code of this
guy's name jordan
you're welcome george enjoy yourself
merry christmas happy birthday
have a good bar mitzvah
you said you wanted to call someone out
jake paul
logan paul any other port i don't care
welcome to london [__]
[Music]
i'm a [__] machine you can't [__]
move me first round decapitation
no head guards 10 ounce gloves someone
is getting knocked out
welcome back to impulsive guys the
number one podcast in the world
liar yeah who's got the number one
podcast in the world
joe rogan so there you go second
third impulsive get it right so just
gonna
let ksi and logan paul have a little
chinwag around my house
i did however see a man in a bus stop
at 7 a.m in newcastle doing this
just another day in newcastle it's nice
when your dad comes to wake you up at
the station isn't it
[Music]
you want to say from behind the scenes
yeah come on give me some one come on
let me so what is it that you would
normally do on this camera here
so well it's funny you should ask me
because um
i'm a bit of an expert with this if you
look at um
you see uh it's very complicated yeah
you weren't
you're just gonna hello jesus christ
i brought a bigger version of you
good to see you yeah how are you i'm
good good
as you know i know [__] on ours our new
set i tried to take some inspo with like
the wood
oh we noticed yeah oh yeah yeah look at
it you just
shipped him like that you just ran with
look how big this guy is you can put
your headlight
definitely not he followed me with it
i've got to be careful
it's different when i met him he was a
kid i know
i got a beard now yeah
if you survive you know floyd mayweather
and even thrive against him like i did
like i'm proud like i got no you did
that
but that's what i'm saying i got combos
on it like no one gets these [__]
nasty like flush combos on floyd you
made a mess yeah bro so
even duck comes a few points [__]
floyd's small let me make them duck
misses a six foot two guy completely you
gotta give credit
at one point you heard floyd teddy
because i can't hit him
that was the best one when they were all
going oh he carried him he carried him
and then you see him in the corner the
guy's going you got to start working the
job he's like hey i can't jab it yeah
i can't do it we saw that we were 75 we
were like
everyone has the moment right where you
meet a celebrity yeah and the first
celebrity i ever met and got a picture
with
was anderson silva [__] hell like
like he was so famous i was so excited
bro it was one of those like oh look who
i'm right in the background
yeah he said that's the you're his goal
which is ironic
yeah i saw it i'm literally good i'm
watching this interview
i'm like how the [__] is it anderson
silva's goal to fight me
bro growing up i wanted to be anderson
silva i was like oh my god that guy's so
badass
i want to i want to fight like him and
be famous like him and now his goal is
to fight me
[Music]
you never look at another man while
eating a banana
yeah i'm glad
yeah yeah katie sonja bro nice question
how are you
good you're tired bro you've been
working the whole week
yeah yeah i heard you guys have been not
talking to me yeah yeah yeah
it's been it's been pretty weird we're
like hey okay okay
take a seat quickly this is some serious
[__] [__] dude which means
um cameras are set cool all right well
do i have to say something first i don't
know where do you what the [__]
happened
nah i mean where do you start um with a
podcast of this magnitude
i mean i mean seriously we got the uk's
biggest stars sitting across from me
ksi in the u.s figure star
it's an honor honestly to welcome you to
impulsive
the number one podcast in the world
that's that's a statistic
it's different when you say like
somebody else is sad right yeah like
he's like yeah the number one
we are in uh london england right now
obviously not on our typical set of
impulsive
we haven't been by the way for months
but this is actually our fred true
geordi's set
he let us bum off his uh property and
also his crew so his crew
are the people filming so thank you guys
i appreciate you uh for this
live studio so many people is here let's
rewind the clock
okay all right there was a time where
you and i
were beating the [__] [__] out of
each other yes
in front of tens of thousands of people
live yes
bro when we fought the second time yeah
in l.a bit of like an off day for me
yeah but i remember being in the ring
with you and like
seeing it in your eyes bro i wasn't like
i was watching you as like a spectator
yeah
while fighting i'm like this guy is
[__] crazy
i go what the [__] he's a dog
jj you're in there just swinging he's
trying to [__] kill me
i'm sure it's great
[Applause]
you need to [__] austin well i need a
[__] austin
guard yeah i'd go and scare the living
[__] out yeah uh jake and then now we
can talk
now we can have a bit of leverage and
it's not like oh
you're the a side i want 70 or blah blah
blah
now it's 50 50 you can't chat [__] yeah
bro like 40 street fights and he does
that what the [__]
i mean here's it i know maybe who's ever
walked away from a fight like that
seven you're not like you know like who
man who punched something at a gas
station it's like 48
put it in the books you know like and
40 like would you what do you [__]
may want to stop and get an equal number
why did jack reese take away two points
five minutes if you wanted to score the
two points
for hitting him when he was now in the
back of the head
not that hard no you still did i know
you were playing dirty bro dirty dog
yeah he's pissing me off what are you
gonna do i was like you [__] [__]
stop
it well you should have heard her saying
to mayweather
were you mad when he got announced to
fight mayweather or you're like that
should be me
i mean i'd [__]
i may have some money for you my friend
we got a money fight on our heads
guys uh thank you for listening to
impulsive number one podcast the world
that's a fact
we love you take it easy guys bye
oh
this is the first picture i've got not
trying to separate these two
it's the first time i can actually relax
okay they're going to be friends after
that's it yeah
fighting is fighting it's hard to like
keep it friendly when you want to
[__]
kill someone like this it's a gladiator
because he's a legend
i got your gift i just oh you got a real
gift i got a gift for you
you let me use your set and you got me
again
all right shut the [__] up
oh you got me a real [__] gift bro
that's hard
holy [__] bro thank you
so sick i don't have any like printed
imagery or anything from the fight so
this is awesome
i'm hitting the months no no this is
crazy the video is taking it as well
it's crazy
seeing floyd have to be nice at the end
and go
he's better than i thought i thought
great young fighter
strong tough he's better than i thought
he was tough
great young fighter he's better than i
thought he was
because you
yeah it was nice i'm glad he liked it
you know
i thought it was great way the way you
talked about the fight and how like his
him looking at you and how it made you
feel and [__] like that because we
haven't really heard yeah
jake's preparing for him and i'm like
hey you can spar as many boxers than you
want
never ever fight someone who's gonna
want it more than him
like he's going to try to [__] you up
yeah
no yeah
no no no two points
he really loves a podcast
yeah it was crazy to get them both
together you know talking just
making just being like your boys
especially [__] so much yeah yeah
do you have the address you have the
address you're a [__] legend
how did you feel good day yeah it was
great um
after watching them try and beat the
hell out of each other for so long just
see them being met
you know especially since um i kind of
did the old um you said you wanted to
call someone out
so i kind of you know and now for them
to be in this studio
and that is a wrap on
ksi on impulsive in the true geordie
studio
the best podcast in the world true
journey podcast
just to be absolutely clear logan
you